the bond when we close off yes good
evening may I come in absolutely thank
you sir hmm it's not too often I make my
way down to skid row this is nice place
not too many drugs being you know I'll
have you know the only reason I'm in
Skid Row is to raise it up and obtain
profit doesn't look like you're raising
its up much looks like you're bringing
it into your living room it's in
progress not that you would know thing
about work well you see petroleum is our
family business that is how he became so
wealthy hmm do you know what petroleum
is even is your brain even heard the
word before your mother's cooking tastes
like ass that's it there's only one way
to solve this and that is a gentleman's
dispute well now we finally found the
way to solve this dispute of us
gentlemen's dispute
let us begin if you even know how to
play how do you play with those buttons
they're done good here we go you daft
prat
I dare say that your mother is the most
fun acacia swimmin on a horse street I
happen to see your family on the corner
just the other day picking up animals
whoring themselves out to animals now
real Daisy Duke that low we were taking
them to the butcher shop what kind of
depraved and fools it's you that
wouldn't have fallen off that does not
prove anything we were getting animals
for the butcher's shop to feed the
homeless not that you'd know anything
about charity work weren't you the one
just talking about how you don't do
charity because it's not profitable oh
please go
oh now who's the depraved are you all
right over there do you need assistance
are you all right well Oh God you cost
yourself inside of me I didn't know this
love we shared was as true as it could
be you know sometimes in conflicts Oh
oh you thought you had me there
sometimes in conflict comes great
friendship
Oh comes great friendship indeed Oh I
knocked your hat clean off I will now
have you that I'm using glue now oh yes
for your hatful for your hair that
you're losing haha it's not very nice my
family is a history of baldness we're
now supposed to be nice we're having a
gentlemen's dispute not of gentlemen's
niceness Nastase Troy's Troy that
stalemates
well the food is going to make the first
move
ha ha you a little late to the party
won't you oh that's not look good for
you Oh three two one
the thing we're not going best-of-three
on the whole round if hibbity miss me
are you gonna have you know I'm just
giving you some false confidence right
I plan on knocking your HEPA really
because that's the objective of this
game - don't hat off oh why not well it
appears we have another stalemate so we
don't owe even more you sleep you barely
my family my family work group of
snipers in the war I'll have you know
that long-range is my specialty
short-range is my specialty take bath
you bastard
how dare you wear another one with you
Oh like I said long range
specialty nodules you didn't even hit me
oh you hit me very hard in the hair did
you have a headache now rich don't you
know that my brain extends far beyond
the ranges of my head that's why I wear
such a large hat because my brain is so
big and I'm fairly certain your hair
your hat has been knocked off many times
in this manner I have not seen a large
brain couldn't hit me if you tried and
it seems like you're trying very hard
brain was so large you wouldn't be on
being from my times my age there you
bring that up
oh yeah oh boy Oh best of three I
suppose we could do such a thing
now I shall show you this expertise of
my family's [ __ ] Ness which is none
didn't you just you just insulted
yourself oh is it nice I said we have no
expertise in Horrors and is talented
you saved yourself at the end thank you
you know in a very not professional way
right just like you did not save
yourself when the IRS came for all of
your earnings on your capital gains
which was very low I'll have you know
that's what you get for bringing that up
oh yes your investment portfolio did not
do too well this evening did it mm-hmm
you lost many on the Dow Jones mother
will recover from horrible monocled of a
mom come on hey I was resting dogs that
yes but you did not your face you're
very slow because I had a little bit of
drinks a Titan told me that you can call
this thing that much of a lightweight oh
you know I had an entire barrel of poo
haha Oh swing a miss a bear
oh look who's up
I'm it's actually try now ha yes Laura's
little so that I can name you moaning
really they destroyed my level but
Hawkes you wouldn't even know what a
buttocks look like it looks like a butts
and an ox combined what Oh what happened
still I believe what what is this Balala
gentlemen number two is superior for one
round we still have a tiebreaker to go
oh do we yes
as we do I think such a dwarf shall fire
with my my skill is unmatched in the
gentleman's dish distill mate oh I'm not
go in go dang it Yuri you see it just
takes a very short amount of time for me
to get the top hat dude yes Punk some
baloney owed you knocked your own hat
off I did not
you are so uncoordinated that you are
your own worst enemy have you know that
my family mastered the levitation I'll
fry the levitation getting your hat
knocked off I'm gonna get at least one
point here I don't believe you will do
such a thing
ah oh please what I think I went through
yeah I think we may have both eat my it
was actually rather nice I've never oh
not rather nice okay I believe you have
it'll come back on
and this service this is where it all
comes out there's the world cup of
gentlemen's disputes would be an epic
battle unlike any okay you you did just
miss me at the magic o equal Oh unless
you in because I pity you you I pity
your minuscule fortune that you made and
in fact you are truly the less gentleman
between the two of us oh is that right
you're the better man and that makes me
the better gentleman because I'm willing
to admit when I'm defeated
that is how it works if I am the better
man therefore I am the better Jim does
that mean whoever loses as long as I
congratulate the winner makes them the
better gentleman oh it's if I lose I win
and if I win I win okay that's good
logic yes the best of logic thank you
for being here yes bold with your
captain of sparkle miss it was actually
mr. droid Apple but thanks for trying
George after that I thought you were
just joking when he said that's a
stupidest name I've ever heard in my
life
toy Wayne check out his empire that he
built in the description what to do and
bye everybody bye
well no matter what the outcome of the
last round whatever you wish what you
know we don't know what it could have
been could have been one of the other we
don't know I think I won but I think he
doesn't want to it we shall go another
round see if the gentlemen Mistah to
ssin of this is more in my inclinations
no really this is only for you yes for
Marvin of course it is I've heard that
one before no one knows that you heard
that right hisses ooh hey-yeah no wasn't
even ready for the slaps oh so many
slaps I am the slap King you don't even
realize how many slaps I can do
don't just wail on it you gotta look you
you got a laceration gotta look at the
angle look how many slaps I am I'm
actually I will admit I am very very
impressed by your thank you thank you
at least your man oh hello I guess it's
time for this now well get ready to die
it's been nice knowing you hang on
dabble has missed I went off a bit
prematurely acquire shooting lessons
understand how you did that but well
it's the red right I like him
totally missing useless go through so
head I'm very impressive well I don't
even know if we need to do another but
do you want to we could more because I'm
just so embarrassed and I'll pour that
would it would be poor gentleman of me
if we let that happen
how dare you so you didn't hear what you
said but but we'll take slaps it was a
little quiet I will admit but mostly
because we can't hear what's going on
all that much yes you slam like floored
eat something slap because I'm very good
at slapping and you slap like a [ __ ]
cat that's because I am what am I then a
blogger you are
100 over a hundred now time for you to
die
get ready I'm strutting my butt towards
you I don't mean to do that
well I did not mean to do this right I
got your other foot you bastard how do
you feel knowing both you hood we'll
never be able to walk again it doesn't
feel good action if you don't know that
I already shot him in the foot go check
out his business channel ding that he
has over in the description or something
yeah I think we've seen who is the
better gentleman here me of course
yeah thanks what no don't hobble off
with your bullet-ridden feet
stop getting blood all over my
impressive bourgeois carpet it's made of
cotton is bourgeois even a material to
make some how what is Buju ah it's like
upper class my booze walk off it you got
blood all over it you made it a red
carpet thank you very much red is in
style these days I've heard Randy is up
your button around the corner so go
screw yourself no stop throttling me no
your damper is molesting me not not
really okay
how [ __ ] I shoot myself ah you just
kept going you talk more tallywacker
you think you can steal business from me
you couldn't even to turn a profit on
your own father whoring ha ha ha lady
may I come in
I killed a wild boar reminded me of your
mother well I pulled the line you should
say that the family is so poor they
couldn't even afford the hubcap off a
Studebaker
what's a Studebaker does that show pop
or my family you know no you actually
got good those actually are timely mix
in my my I wasn't calling your mama horn
your hat is worth less than your mother
on Hall Street nice place it's a nice
place my place
Skid Row I don't make my way down here
that butcher but occasionally I do
I'm find the time what Dexter I'll make
my way down here a lovely place for
someone in the poorhouse I've come to
tell you that your mother's the cheapest
[ __ ] on [ __ ] alley she has been known
to not be very good at cooking your
father can't afford a pipe
you weren't born with a silver spoon in
your mouth more like it was made of tin
lovely place for a peasant I've come to
tell you that you're a tough brass and
he seemed to be a little drum you see
all this machinery here you probably got
it from my company what's the name of
your company
it's appliance isn't Co [ __ ] sis it Co
not deleting some girl
thank you know that it's you careless do
the wheel brained black bear hmm what is
this Fang technology that I hold in my
hand you wouldn't know because you're
too poor to afford this stuff you made
made by people you pay a fair wage mines
made by slaves you roguish tickle brain
strumpet hmm nice delayed reaction good
acting here your father would have given
you up birth if you hadn't gotten polio
my own I can't be seen interacting with
the poor you know this well I killed a
lion next time I was in Africa and it
reminds me of no one in your family
because it was much greater than them
all
you killed it the next time you were in
Africa are you from the future get what
they say yes you did no but you should
have your mama's a [ __ ]
how dare you sir I'll have you know that
her whoring raised this family from the
ground up it looks like you're still on
the ground right now I am on the second
floor thank you very much not that
anyone should know that
so the trash is piled so high up outside
that it's piled in your living room
exactly I take great relish in my trash
and I musta to ketchup cause hot out
here
but yeah good jokes I'm gonna end it
screw in this travesty game